hello everybody i'm marcos this is me
and there's a tiny giraffe over there
which is very cute ah i'm marcos I'm 11
github and Twitter and also stuff I can
always use a charcoal and i work at
continued net and continuum analytics
one of the sponsor of the e of t
conference so today i'm going to be
talking about reproducibility we're
going to define what is a development
environment what tools or but things are
out there that we can use to help us a
reproduce our environment and what it
would be really nice to have so when i
start with the definition which at this
point i think everybody knows what is
what is very produced ability and why is
it so hard for me to pronounce but we
basically we have we want to make an
experiment i want to be able to make the
same thing or tip the same result in
another place whether it is by the same
person or by by other people in our case
since we're talking about software we
basically want the things to work we won
I don't want to compile when a bill that
we want to see the website we want to
see the same Association we want the
thing to run so in that case we're going
to go a little bit more deep on worries
i develop an environment these are a few
the finishes that I just found online in
two seconds a google procedure and it's
basically it's a bunch of procedures
tools that for people who are the
stopper need to build and deploy their
software these are three definitions
just found them real quick no no big
deal about this then also found like a
described research from people from IBN
like they made like a more defined
definition of what is a development
environment and they came out with three
components method tools enablement
organization infrastructure and adoption
from ilysm three of them only are
morning but with people like how are you
going to have our team using or adopting
our development environment which
organization tools that are going to
help us provide that and how are you
wanna encourage other people from the
organization to use them so I'm just I
just cross them out because I'm not
going to talk about that I'm just gonna
focus on when it is method which is this
Kel in this case is roles standards
check these templates and development
approach to polishing in this is case
I'm gonna say that it has to do more
with the way we work like for instance
what guidelines are we using what
templates are we using in order to
continue working and checklist and what
are these standards and we use this has
to do a lot with a high follow I follow
anyway we also have tools tools are in
this in our case is mostly software it's
going to be our de repo it's going to be
other tools that we use whether it's the
weather is producing get or bizarre some
tool like that to got a for the version
management or the the repository it's
gonna be the topology that were using
whether if we where you seen some
services outside or where or using
everything local or we're using some
sort of database or some sort of a
cluster are no configuration
infrastructure is a little bit more it's
like a weird mixture between the last
two in this case is going to be a
software going a bit more specific like
what is the operating system what is the
database that we're going to be using
different levels of control and how are
we going to be testing operating system
is very important here because like
people who are doing software they
already know that it's sometimes it's
hard to compile the same thing in not
everything's closed platform so
something can work it's only designed to
be functioning linux it may not work on
North stain or maybe windows
and if you are also doing mobile
development like in cell phones that
escalates real quick and that's why it's
the same if the system is April it's
prepared to be working with postgres we
cannot just plug in a my sequel or maybe
[ __ ] it's we have to be very specific
about that and there's no there's no
question about it but in our case we
work with data like going a little bit
more on our use cases I just a point a
few things that we usually do like for
instance some people work in an
environment well everything's production
like if you're not working on on a
product or non software you're just
doing like a quick note book to prove
something and then you want to share
with your peers the notebook is
production as soon as you're done with
that you're going to just publish it
somewhere whether it's keith hub whether
it's any viewer or anaconda or that is
your final product you can also be
working in an environment a little bit
more traditional where you do have the
development environment of your computer
you have a testing environment somewhere
else and you also have production which
may be another and our platform if
you're working windows you may be
deploying we nurse or maybe in another
are no in Linux so those things are
going to be thinking about it it's
definitely multi-language right nowadays
just saying that I can only write Python
it's obviously not enough at some point
you need to write sequel you might need
to write our Bosh but there's so many
languages that it's very hard to keep
them keep them in mind we also work in
different configurations some people
just work locally if you have a few not
so much data you can just download it to
your computer and work from there some
other people have like so much data that
they can do that so they work mostly in
the cloud and that can be for instance a
using a cluster yeah cluster in the
cloud weather is the cloud like Amazon
or rusher or weather is the internal
cloud in your in your organization
and somebody some people also do a
little bit of both where you have a lot
of data but you have the option to just
sample the later and just take a few
chunks of data download it to your local
workstation i work from there so this
and of course the how much data we have
some people just gigs terabytes or just
whatever is coming afterwards petabytes
and you know we all know how can let's
go crazy so after all of those after a
few definitions what do we actually want
to reproduce I think I one element that
the for me is very important especially
if you work in the team are calling
styles and document the orientation
styles like people you when I'm you
wanna have people working and writing
the code more or less the same way so
it's it's more readable for the rest of
the team and you have more people who
are being able to work on maybe add a
add value Tory to your software of
course but with this is the most common
thing that when we talk about
environments which is basically the
dependencies like we just say okay I'm
going to need okay when I'm going to
need Django or I'm going to need I don't
know pandas or some other library but we
also have to take in account the dead
base whatever database that we use him
if we're using her or not or what's
going to be the source of a data we also
and this is something very important for
me is configuration files and
environment variables it's something
that we usually forget but not everybody
has the same installation of postgres or
the mice equally have just lil
customizations that we need to share
across our team or across whoever wants
to use that so that's something that is
very easy to forget and we should always
keep it into account sometimes we also
want to share data especially if you
wanna like polish something in our know
in MV viewer or github but there's no
way to share data so I just just omit
this for now and lastly I just name
these keys which would be like Amazon
keys usher keys SSH keys to our own
servers or any kind of any kind of file
that has like a the winning you need to
be secure for coating on the
commendation styles there's a lot
outside there's a lot of guides like II
there's one called ta hip 8 which is
like the one that is a included in
Python there's a total flake aight
that's going to help us evaluate or call
if you weren't complying to that guide
or not there's also one from google
which is called yet another Python
format and us we also have these kind of
guys for other software like JavaScript
or Ruby or whatever to a premier
languages with that we're going to use
we do have some styles we can use tools
like linters to help us take a look at
where being compliant to style and
there's other tools that I didn't add
that they basically yeah this is pretty
much it there's also ide configurations
if some people are using tools like
pycharm or em I can take an eclipse a
they usually you can make a
configuration you can attach the
configuration to your repo so everybody
that's going to have access to your repo
has access to the same configuration and
in that case they can be using more less
the same tools from the idea that you're
using just I think that's very handy for
the people that don't use IDEs they'd
like more broth system like beam atom or
maybe sublime 2x that it's very popular
right now there's the super editor comfy
which basically lets its allows you to
add a configuration file for your repo
when you say I want in this nation to be
four spaces and i wanna i wanna i don't
know
every file that is Python I won't have
four spaces invitation for JavaScript
files I'm gonna have two spaces or
whatever you want whatever starts you
define you can define them in your repo
so you can share that with your with
your team very easily and in case you're
working with documentation there's tools
like Sphinx in MK dogs in Python that as
long as you respect a structure they
provide you can compile it from there so
that's also going to force the people
who work with you to write a well
formatted documentation again one of the
most important thing is always
dependencies whether it's dead based we
usually have to take an account
installation instructions which they're
very tricky because they they're not the
same whether if you're using Windows
Linux or OS 10 so if you want to have
your team having access to your
deployment bottom very quickly you
should document the steps that you take
that you're taking to install the
database engine you also want to share
the schema and the configuration or
dummy data in case you you need it an
easy way to do those things is there are
some tools that provide migrations like
for instance Django has a system
migration so you can just attach all of
that to your repo and as soon as I
repeat any other person wants to use it
as you can just enable and have more or
less the same configuration as you
actually the same contradiction with you
you can also use software as a service
mean you can use a database provider
amazon so you just ask the people to
connect to that database on nobody has
to worry about how to compute or do
anything else there's a lot out there
and I think they're kind of vulnerable
so you can also use make files or bash
scripts in order to help people with
installation make files are very handy
if you're using Linux or OS 10 if you're
using something like Windows used to
think about batch files which I'm
super familiar with them I'm lastly the
new thing dr. Baker is when you you
wanna this is like super cool you can
have a revolution of environment
container in a new machine you basically
in dr. you have a container container
it's like a process that has that's
basically running another operating
system where you can have your own my
sequel or your own whatever that's what
you want and whoever's installed that
container can have the exact same same
thing as you the only property is that
you're basically adding a little bit
mode overhead you sometimes need to
utilize beautiful eyes but it's
definitely something that it's something
that is a lot of people are using right
now and I think it's pretty fantastic
and always try to ultimate us automate
as much as possible that's gonna help
people not make mistakes then when we
talk about libraries especially in
Python I think we have like two big
options just one more which is easy
installed but I don't know how broadly
use this so in this case I only focus on
peep on Conda I'm pretty sure everybody
know everybody here are familiar with
this at least is too but I will with a
tiny comparation peep is basically the
most well-known it has a lot of packages
there's so many options over there and
from other hand condensed more focusing
on data so that Conda is is maintained
by continuum and also by the community
if you're familiar with anaconda is the
tool that we are using to build anaconda
on on another aspect peep since its
Python it's multi-platform but you're
not sure that at the library that you're
installing is going to run in another
life another platform because you just
don't know that it's it's never been
built that's not always true now that we
have tools like wheeler that we
basically download
compiled packages so they they are
closed but they can be proposed platform
on the other hand we have Conda which is
it is multi-platform because we built or
if you want to build the packages across
way if you want if you have people using
Windows you can just build it for
windows and that's going to guarantee
that it's going to work over there one
is a little bit faster than the other
one that's also not true if you if you
download packages already compile and
they both work they're both including
anaconda so you can just use it this I'm
gonna do that so in the case of people
how do we extract how do we grab all the
dependencies that we are using it and
how the how can we share them there's AG
subcommand called freeze we basically
called the fries I point that to a file
and we end up with utter all the list of
dependencies it's usually good advice to
whatever you want to start a project
start fresh like create a new create a
new environment you can use butyl am or
PM if you're using Python 3 so you can
start fresh and you're sure that the
dependency that your listing over there
are the one that you're going to need to
run whatever you're using and this is
like a little bit of advice like in this
case I do think that the specific
specification it going it goes too far
like I know that I we need request 2.8 I
don't know if I did Rickles to point a
pool point 1 point 1 because the last
digit of the of the version is usually
the bug-fix release release so i usually
want the latest as possible so my advice
is always to take this one out like I
want to point eight I don't care about
the back fix released but if you want to
be super specific you can of course at
it in here that is instruction in order
if you're if you want to create a new
environment and start fresh as I was
saying
in the game in in the case of Conda is
more or less the same we use the sub
comment all M which is going to extract
the environment and in this case is
going to send it to a file i have a very
confuse name that's the name of the
environment that's wrong and then when
took when we take a look at the at the
result is again I think it's like two is
going too far like I don't always need
the build number but I may just use her
or not I usually just remove these guys
another thing that I thought I think
it's very inconvenient from Python when
you use these kind of tools like export
or phrase is that it's always going to
extract all the packages that I have
himself like all of them so some
libraries have dependencies have
specific dependencies for windows or
specific dependencies for linux and if I
extract all of them those servers may
not be I won't be able to install some
of them in another platform so I i
usually don't recommend people to do
this I think it's so much worse if you
curate your own requirements or
environment the ammo file by your own so
every time you install something you
know I don't know you say okay I'm going
to use Jupiter so you start Jupiter and
you added here by hand instead of adding
with all the dependencies because you
don't know if what you're actually
adding over there there are these tools
I think it's very convenient they they
look in the code all the imports and
they try to guess what are going to be
the dependencies so if you already been
working there you don't remember what
you install I think it's worth to give
it a try to these pigs and defrost seems
super handy
this is a tool that I mail which is it's
like an alternative to Conda environment
the difference in circa is that it's
going to install all the dependencies in
in the in whatever the directory that
you're standing on so you can
encapsulate or as I want to say you're
going to create like a pill with all the
with all the packages and for me the
cool thing about this is that i can just
remove the director that I'm creating
and I don't have any anything yet
there's no I don't have anything else
it's super easy and clean to to make it
disappear well notebooks are like super
popular among this community so I just
wanted to show some tools that we made
whenever you start working the project
we first installs whatever we want to
use we work on a notebook this is how
you find out good and when if you want
to sure this we have this subcommand
attached but basically it's going to
take all the dependencies installed in
the current environment and it's going
to put it inside the metadata of the
notebook so then with another way you
can do whatever you want you can share
it on github on on a guest or you seen
anaconda or just email whatever you do
as soon as you want to use it somewhere
else you can just create an environment
from using the same file this is going
to go inside the meta data extract the
dependencies and inside it whatever you
want to do in whatever it computers you
when i use so i think this is a very
cool solution when you you're working
with a notebook i'll you want other
people to take a look at the same
notebook you don't need to add any other
file just you ship the notebook and
that's enough the dependencies are
inside the mirror that they are living
inside there the notebook
other things that as i was talking at
the beginning other things very
important to sure to reproduce is the
configuration people usually use yahoo
files any files or JSON whatever it file
you want to use you want to make sure
that you attach that to your report you
want to make sure that people have
access to them and they're using them in
a neural system the problem is that we
usually start this in as i want to say i
like to say programmers brain like the
leader of the project knows that the
size of the block of memory for whatever
database is 16 megs and that's the only
person who knows this should we should
always avoid that so we should always
attached to the repo document and I also
found this tool out of em which i think
is pretty cool you can put a file dot I
think it's dot m in your directory in
your repo with all the steps that you
need I don't know if you wanna if you
don't have some environment variables
available if you want to make some
configuration if you want to change
something you can put it over there so
as soon as use CD into the directory
this outer one tool is going to capture
the file is when I secured whatever it
is inside so did this also could be very
dangerous or no be careful and lastly
Keith I don't think there's any standard
on how the we shirk like SSH keys or
amazon keys or password the most
important thing here is don't put it in
the repo especially if you're doing open
source just don't do that can be very
very expensive especially if you're
sharing your amazon keys over there
their stories about people growling get
help finding keys and taking advantage
of them 24 create their own instance so
be very careful about that and I don't
have any suggesting here to just talk to
your tea department
some some deployment system have their
own like you I where you can attach the
keys if you want to deploy like elastic
beam or Heroku just I don't know this is
very specific to the pressure guy you're
working on and I just don't think
there's a standard and some conclusions
so I don't know how is your experience
when someone new joins the team I think
in my case is it's always been painful
like it's always this new person he or
she is going to spend a day or maybe two
installing everything downloading the
source code getting the data and getting
up to speed just having the the project
running or building takes forever I and
I explore so many options it just can't
find any good solution especially when
you have your team with everybody you
seen or stained and someone shows up
with a linux machine or the other way
out or vice versa like you just don't
even know how to install Python in the
machine or something like that or so and
I just don't understand why so painful
that's me this is my catharsis I think
that the people who do who's working
with development or DevOps they have all
the stuff already covered like they can
they can give you a machine with it some
sort of database some configuration and
they can do that in minutes and I think
we should also be working towards that
direction to collect more standards way
to share the configuration more standard
ways to share our development to I don't
know find the process and this is what I
have questions yes
again about for using confidence yes yes
I'm gonna put it on my github but I'm
gonna I'm gonna tweet about this like in
a minute so this is the key attached
that's basically going to go to your the
packages that you have installed and
it's gonna grab a list and put it inside
the meta data so if you have a directory
where you have so this is the name of
the environment so you can totally do
that so you can say okay this notebook
is going to have this environment so on
this other notebook other m and by other
dependencies
no I think you can use cut in that case
I don't think there's an issue is away
right now but that's a good suggestion
though oh yeah awesome we from the the
the cat thing oh nice thank you oh yeah
we didn't when you're running the
notebook yeah totally all right
yes
so I think there are people who are
sharing the data across using s3 but
sometimes your data is private so you
can use that and I'm not sure how would
you ship gigs of data like there's a lot
of solution and there's no standard way
some people use Dropbox and people just
put in the repo some people give us
three keys some people just ship you in
the hard drive like there's so many and
I couldn't find any consistent way our
more standardized way yes indeed
all right thank you very much